Oh, everybody. This episode of the show is brought to you by magic spoon.
If you're a regular viewer of my child, I'm going to put that down.
You'll know that I'm a big fan of cereal because well,
who isn't cereal is awesome, but it's not always good for you.
There were several years where I just didn't eat cereal because you know,
usually it's got just more sugar than you need in your life.
I don't really have the healthiest diet in the world,
but generally I tend to stay in okay.
Shape by not eating tons of unnecessary sugar, as you'd normally find in cereal.
Anyway, along comes a company called magic spoon, and they're like,
somebody's got to try this. There's no sugar. There's hardly any carbs.
And there's 11 grams of protein. And I'm like, I had coms were bad.
I didn't really know much about them. Honestly. I know protein is good,
but this one, no sugar, but it tastes amazing. It's also keto friendly,
gluten free, low carb. GMO-free all of that good stuff as well.
And originally they had four flavors.
I was actually eating the cocoa ones today,
which is one of the original four flavors just because that's what I felt like.
But recently they sent me these two answers.
Can you guys still hear me cinnamon,
which I saw cannot be beat that wasn't until they introduced peanut butter
flavor and all the Americans. When I did a,
an add on another channel like seven, have you never had peanut butter cereal?
I'm like, it just, wasn't a thing.
When I was growing up in the UK and now I've had it.
I'm never going back. Zero sugar, three grams of net carbs,
seven grams of protein. This is magic spoon. It is wonderful.
Get yourself a personalized cereal box with custom flavors. It's perfect.
Anyway, click the link below,
or just go to magic spoon.com for slash biographics and build your own variety
pack. I can try it out. Use my promo code.
Biographics you'll get free shipping a hundred percent happiness guarantee if
you don't like it, money back and let's get into the video.
If you've watched our video on the summit of man and enjoyed it,
then you're in luck.
As we are about to explore a similarly puzzling case involving an unidentified
body and an investigation with plenty of unexpected twists and turns.
That sounds like that pulls right out of an inflaming novel.
This one is 50 years old and comes to us from Norway.
When hikers found the burned body of a woman in the foothills outside Bergen,
they did not know they were about to trigger one of the greatest mysteries in
the country's history. It is known as the is doll women,
and it is proven to be remarkably enduring with many crime buffs,
not just due to the fact that the victim remains unidentified,
but because of all the circumstantial evidence that strongly suggests the
possibility that she may have been a spy disguises, fake identities,
counterfeit passports, secretive behavior, and to gory unsolved deaths.
This case had them all. So sit back, relax.
As we take a look at the most mystifying cold case from the cold war,
the iStar.
[Inaudible].
It's stolen,
literally ice Valley is a basin at the foothills of Mount Aurukun and Norway
near the city of Bergen.
That is also called death Valley by the locals because it used to be a common
spot hundreds of years ago.
And it was also the place where some trackers fell to that deaths during heavy
fog in the 1960s, despite its macabre reputation,
it says remains a popular hiking spot. Back on November, the 29th,
1970 a father and his two daughters decided to spend the morning crossing their
Starlin.
They were hoping it would be a fun outdoor activity and a good bit of exercise,
but the experience turned into something far more sinister as they were hiking
across the foothills. The trio noticed a strange burning smell.
It looked around them and saw a grim sight.
It was a corpse that had been set on fire.
It was the body of a woman spread across some rocks and with its arms extended
forward, like a boxer, a common occurrence in burn victims.
Once the family got over the shock,
they alerted the police who arrived quickly on the scene and opens an
investigation.
First thing they noticed was that the women did not appear to be a regular
hiker.
The starters she was found off the beaten path in and out of the way place.
There was not used for walking. The body was burned beyond recognition,
but only on the front, her head hair and face were all heavily charged,
but her back was mainly untouched.
Police initially thought that women might've thrown herself backward after
somehow catching fire,
which would explain why only her front was burned and how she ended up in a
remote area. However, they could not find any trace of a campfire.
So she was either burned in a different way or another person cleaned up the
scene afterwards, despite the lack of a campfire,
there were certainly plenty of other items at the scene,
but they too made investigators raise their eyebrows.
None of them pointed at a possible ID. There were personal effects, jewelry,
a watch, some bottles, a broken umbrella,
but they were all positioned in a weird way beside the body and what the
forensic investigators described as some kind of ceremony.
There were also lots of items of clothing. Most of them partially burned,
but the strange thing was that they all had their tags cut off.
So they couldn't be identified. Even the bottles had their labels removed.
The body was too damaged to get a good impression of what the women used to look
like. However,
by jumping ahead just a bit so we can provide the description that they obtained
at a later date and then sent into a, for some international assistance.
They described the woman as being between 25 and 40 years old,
164 centimeters in height weighing 56 kilograms with symbols and Brown
eyes. She had broad hips, small face, small ears and long brownish blank.
One in a ponytail tied with the blue and white prints ribbon from the remains of
our clothes.
It is believed she was wearing a dark blue bubble nylon jacket and matching
belts. Closing in the fronts with two into lockable rings,
they green and blue check William shawl,
the dark blue machine that sweater dark blue slacks with a front zip black
Jersey, long underwear, dark blue panties, blue pattern, sports stockings,
semi long blue rubber boots with white soles and drunk leasing Brown,
fake fat Cape.
Her jewelry included steel sports wristwatch with solo trademark rounds,
gold filigree earrings, and a gold ring set with a large cameo,
as you might have already guessed by now,
none of this proved useful as the victim still remains on identifying to this
day with no other name. She became known as the installer.
[Inaudible].
The local police from Bergen could tell that this would not be a normal
investigation. So they asked for help from the country's elite police service,
the national criminal investigation surface or Crip us.
The team found its first big league.
Just a few days after the body had been located that are local tourist spots in
bargain to keep an eye out for unclaimed luggage.
They then found two large suitcases that had been left at the luggage office.
If the railway station in Bergen, one of them contains a pair of sunglasses,
which had a fingerprint on the lens,
which was then matched the body in the ice Valley.
There could be no doubt that the police had located the luggage of the adult
women among other things. The suitcases contained clothes, cosmetics teaspoons,
a comb and a hairbrush to have eczema cream and five different types of
currency,
but mostly German Marx and Norwegian kroner also inside were multiple wigs and
prescription eyewear that had only regular glass and no corrective lenses.
Both of these would have proven useful to someone looking to disguise
themselves. At this point,
investigators were certain that an identification was only going to be a matter
of time, but as they carefully went through the contents of the suitcases,
examining them all piece by piece, that confidence was plummeting.
It seemed that the same care had been shown to these items as had been to the
ones found alongside the install women. Again,
all identifiers have been removed, clothing tags, cosmetic labels,
even the prescription sticker on the eczema cream.
Somebody wants to make sense and that nobody would find out the identity of the
bunny.
Even though the suitcases did not help the police identify the install women,
they did provide them with two clues,
a shopping bag and a writing pad with some notes on it. First, the shopping bag,
it was labeled Oscar wrote about his footwear store,
which was located in the city of Stavanger.
It was strange that somebody who had been so meticulous about removing all other
brand names would leave this behind,
but the police were just happy to have a solid lead. They traveled,
just have anger and talk to the owner's son who remembered the victim is a very
well dressed, nice looking woman with dark hair and a calm and quiet expression.
Firstie confirmed what everybody already expected. She was a foreigner.
The woman spoke English, but with an accent.
And since he thought that she had an unusual sense,
which he later concluded was garlic. The owner's son gave the police.
The first detailed description of the women found in the DePaul bulletin that we
mentioned previously.
He said that she had come in three weeks out looking to buy a pair of boots.
She took her time examining the designs close up before settling on the pair of
blue boons from these celebrity line of ask him gummy VEGF fabric.
They weren't wrapped. In fact,
they were one of the most popular models in the entire country, but crucially,
they matched the burn boots found on the body,
providing police with confirmation that they were talking about the same person.
Then there was the other clue.
The notepad only the first page had writing on it,
which consisted of multiple series of letters and numbers.
It looked like a code and the police managed to crack a part of it.
It's after a few days of work, it wasn't anything shady, but it was strange.
The code seemed to be a travel record.
Presumably noting all the places where the installment had traveled,
where it said, Oh, two, two Oh two eight P for example,
denoted a stay in Paris between October the 22nd and the 28th.
It was followed by Oh two nine PS, which meant that on October the 29th,
she left Paris Vista Banga afterwards came Oh three, zero B and five,
which matched up to her stay in Bergen between October the 30th of November,
the fifth. These were eventually corroborated by other bits of evidence.
But most of the note remains undecided mainly because each city was only marked
with a single letter.
And it would be impossible to know for certain which cities these refer to,
but even so it showed Norwegian police that the victim was a well-traveled woman
who moved quickly from city to city. Up until this point,
the only concern seemed to be finding out the identity of the install women and
to watch what happens out.
But increasingly that was starting to wonder what business brought out to
Bergen.
Especially as rumors started flying around that she may not have just been an
innocent bystander.
[Inaudible].
The install woman was a spy was not very far fetched.
There was the middle of the cold war.
After all an espionage was a constant threat or this whole thing took place less
than three years before the Lillehammer affair.
When Israeli agents from the Maasai traveled to Norway,
to assassinate and innocent Moroccan waiter and mistaking him for one of the
leaders of the black September militant groups that was responsible for the 1972
summer Olympics massacre in Munich,
even though they would not admit it until decades later, noise,
military intelligence branch,
the Norwegian intelligence service or NIS had launched their own investigation
into the install women.
But they were more concerned with finding out the reason why she visited Bergen
after a while. It wasn't exactly a hotspot for international tourists back then,
but that was some military tests with new rockets being performed in the area.
Their reports turned out to be inconclusive back with the regular police.
They were still trying to figure out who the iStar women was.
They had a good description of her, thanks to the salesman at the shoe store.
And it's the fact that she was arrest site and Stavanger and bug and any made
him more memorable. Sure enough. After visiting a few hotels,
they discovered the one she'd been staying at in Stavanger.
It was the hotel since firsthand located close to the shoe store.
The receptionist that remembered a woman who matched the description.
And I remember of the cleaning staff also recalled seeing how wearing the blue
boots that she had purchased from the store. This had to be the same person.
And she had checked in under the name for Nyla log from Belgium.
So did the Norwegian police just identify the iSTYLE woman was the end of the
case in sight? Well, of course we know that was not what happened,
but in the moment they thought their prospects were looking pretty good. First,
they reached out to Interpol and Belgium police to help tracking down their
victim.
Then they tried to retrace our steps between Stavanger and Bergen and find out
which hotel she was staying at in the last city.
This is where the case gets even more complicated.
There was nobody called Fenella law who had checked in at any hotel in Bergen.
She had used a fake name and somewhere between Stavanger and Bergen,
she had changed our identity.
This also meant the police were back to square one,
Maybe not quite square. One investigators might not have had a name,
but at least they had a handwriting back then all foreigners who visited Norway
have to fill in an alien registration form to check into a hotel.
It contains the person's name, address, passport number and signature,
which also implies that the install women had a fake passport under the name
Fenella law.
Otherwise she would not have been able to check into the hotel since Fitton
sends police and the forms she filled out in Stavanger,
they brought in handwriting experts to compare writing samples collected from
other registration forms from hotels, all over the country, not just Bergen,
even in such a strange case, what they discovered still proved to be a surprise,
as it turns out the women had stayed in multiple hotels in Norway,
under numerous assumed identities,
which must've meant that she had access to a lot of fake passports.
She also pretended to be Claudia tilt from Brussels Genevieve last year from
live in Vera jar from Antwerp.
And there's a business need and HAFA from Austin's Gloria Nielsen from Ganz and
Alexia, Zara Marquez from the Biana under these names.
She had checked into hotels, not just in Bergen and starving it,
but also Oslo and Trondheim before her death. For example,
she first stayed at hotel Rosencranz for two days before moving to a hotel Horta
Hyman for another five days,
both located in Bergen and to the is at least one more fake name, there,
a sugar snack, which she had used in Paris,
but who knows how many identities she really had?
You might've noticed that most of the names came from cities in Belgium,
Norwegian police thought this might be because she was an actual citizen of that
country. This Belgian authorities investigated the case on their end.
It could find no solid leads. Unsurprisingly, all of the names used were fake.
The whole spy idea was becoming more and more plausible at the very least.
She definitely was not just a tourist who was in the wrong place at the wrong
time. That had to be some kind of clear ulterior purpose to our actions.
But Norwegian authorities were still struggling to discover what that could have
been after talking with the hotel staff who remembered to our police found out
that the iStar woman also spoke German.
And on one occasion she had dinner in the dining hall next to a German Navy
officer. Although the two did not appear to interact together,
none of the peculiar detail was that the woman often requested a change of rooms
at these hotels that she was staying at. And in one case,
she asked to change rooms three,
While the police were busy, chasing down leads,
the forensic pathologists were working to see what data they could obtain from
the body itself. Unfortunately,
the autopsy did not exactly prove to be a treasure trove of new information.
Arivale did the,
as Darwin had never given birth or been pregnant is uncovered a bruise on the
side of her neck, which could have come from an altercation,
but it could have also resulted from a fall.
The woman had been in good health antibodies showed no signs of any serious
illnesses that being said.
She had suffered an excruciating death traces of Petro with founds,
which was used to set her on fire and the presence of certain other smoke
particles in our lungs indicated that she was alive while burning.
She had lethal concentrations of carbon monoxide in her blood.
She had also swallowed huge amounts of sleeping Bill's phenoma prior to our
death between 50 and 70,
but they did not yet have time to fully dissolve and get absorbed into our
bloodstream. According to the autopsy,
the headstone woman died from carbon monoxide poisoning combined with ingesting
a huge quantity of sleeping pills because of this Norwegian police labeled her
official cause of death as probable suicide.
Although many are skeptical of this conclusion.
One investigator said in a recent interview that very few of them actually
believe the death was suicide due to the remoteness of the location where the
body was found, but even more so due to the extreme method employed,
very few people set themselves on fire as a means of suicide.
And on the other hand,
if she only intended to take the sleeping pills and Sater self ablaze by
accident, and what happened to the campfire,
there was still more questions left unanswered than there were at the beginning
of the investigation. However,
with no more leads to pursue and an official cause of death,
the case was closed in February, 1971.
This tall woman is given a Catholic funeral attended by the officers who
investigated her death. And she was buried in an unmarked grave.
There was one part of her that was not buried with the rest, her teeth.
There's still a woman has a lot of work done on her teeth.
So investigators kept her jaw in the hopes that it might be useful in an
identification. She had 14 fillings and unusually high number for a woman.
Her age. Most of them had pre-made gold crowns,
which are unlike those used in Scandinavia. At the time, again,
this clue helped prove that the iStore woman was not a local that's.
That was something that everybody already knew by that point.
Those types of crowns were more common in Southern and central Europe,
but they failed to provide a more specific localization.
Ultimately it was another dead end, the case laid dormant for decades.
And it wasn't until a few years ago that new progress was made,
which might eventually help us solve the mystery of the install women.
[Inaudible].
Like with many other decades, old cold cases.
There is always a hope that modern technology and new investigative methods
might be able to yield additional information in ways that would have simply
been impossible to achieve back when the crimes were originally committed.
However, in this instance,
the nucleus also benefited from a bit of serendipity after the case was closed
in 1971,
a professor of dentistry named Jazelle bang kept the DOL women's jaw in the
hopes that somebody else might one day recognize their handiwork.
He sent images to countless colleagues,
had them published in dentistry journals,
but it all proved fruitless as nobody came forward.
Eventually the professor died and everybody assumes that the drawer had been
discarded according to his success.
And the records mentioned that the bone had been thrown away because it had
started to smell. We fast forward now to 2017, when journalists from NRK noise,
public broadcasting company,
we're working on a new investigation into the install women,
a bit of research on their part revealed that the jaw had not been destroyed,
but rather preserved in the archives of Hawkins university hospital.
This were going to investigators with the opportunity to re-examine the evidence
with new technology. And soon enough,
they hailed a major breakthrough researchers at the university of Bergen did an
isotope analysis on the teeth in order to establish what they called a chemical
signature.
This was originally created when the teeth were first formed and it was altered
along the way by which compounds were absorbed at specific stages of teeth
developments.
It was the first time that this technique was employed by Norwegian police,
but it paid dividends.
Is it narrowed down the place of origin for the unidentified woman.
Tentatively scientists believed that she might've been born in the area around
the city of Nuremberg in Germany,
and then relocated further West before her teenage years,
somewhere in the border area between Germany, France, Belgium, and Luxembourg,
her age was also revised. Thanks to the bone analysis previously,
there was only a vague approximation to go on,
which said that the iStar women was between 25 and 40 years old at the time of
our death. This new estimate placed to age at the higher end of that scale,
saying that she was around 40 years old when she died, give or take four years,
there is also another tool to consider genetic genealogy.
This is the current darling of the forensic world after helping put to bed
multiple high profile cold cases in recent years,
it's naturally that of the infamous golden state killer.
There is hope that it might be able to do the same with iStar women.
Scientists have been able to create a DNA profile while isotope analysis.
If a tooth enamel revealed that she was born sometime around 1930,
probably near or in Nuremberg. And later she moved closer to the Western border.
It's not exactly a slam dunk,
but it is the first solid lead in almost five decades.
And a good enough reason to believe that this is one mystery that might be
solved in the years to come. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to check it off. Fantastic sponsor magic spoon.
There is a link below. Thank you.
[Inaudible].